hallo leute kennt ihr das es ist ende
des monats und ihr seid mal wieder knapp
bei kasse
wenn der ladendieb steinig ausreicht
gehe ich auch mal gerne eine bank
ausrauben
warte mal ausrauben räuber raum aus
räuber sind auch ghana braunau über
grauen umgang von und untergang
das klingt ja genauso wie die neue
sendung von radio bremen die ab dem 27
januar immer dienstags um 18 50 im
ersten läuft das ist ja komisch genau
die ihr mich letztens erst gefragt ob
ich ein video darüber machen möchte dass
diese sendung jetzt losgeht weil man
nämlich einfach das hier und nenne es
credit suisse darf sein argument money
edition - beginnen wir mit dem make-up
ich mag es da sehr natürlich denn eine
bank ausrauben bedeutet stress und da
fange ich echt schnell an zu schwitzen
also mädels der unvergessene bruder bei
den herren könnte eigentlich ganz frei
sein
ich bin es gerne perücke denn wir wollen
der polizei nicht zu leicht machen so
mit meinem gesicht bin jetzt eigentlich
zufrieden
fehlt nur noch das richtige outfit mein
absolutes must-have sind schwarze
turnschuhe und dazu die passende
sporthose absoluten logos sind
ballerinas oder high heels das
wichtigste fehlt noch ein guter
bankräuber bei sich zu vermummen
und da könnt ihr eurer kreativität
freien lauf lassen
ich bevorzuge immer noch das kleine
schwarze bzw
die kleine schwarze jetzt fehlt nur noch
die tasche und bei der gelegenheit
könnte ich ja eigentlich ein kleines
watts in my back machen damit ich
wirklich für alle situationen gewappnet
bin nämlich immer mein leatherman mit
der ist winzig klein und praktisch und
wir gehen mit dem trend ein ring für
jeden finger
der schlagring für durchschlagende
erfolge und ein deo
naja ihr wisst schon so ich mache mich
jetzt auf dem weg und hoffen dass euch
das video gefallen hat als nächstes gibt
es dann eine rallye mit nie vor gelassen
also erstmal danke an radio bremen für
die zusammenarbeit und somit wurde ich
gerade produktplatzierung
na ja auch wenn es jetzt nicht wirklich
ein produkt wenn ihr noch mehr illegale
videos familie sehen wollt dann gibt es
links molotow-cocktails das mal wieder
richtig brenzlig werden soll und rechts
gibt's ein neues malen mit wanne wo ihr
ganz leicht eure eigenen geldscheine
basteln kann
also leute bis zum nächsten mal
a